They spent what, a trillion dollars
trying to get one dude back from Mars?
You get the opportunity
to bring back Matt Damon.
I just don't think we should
wait around to be saved, you know?
You really don't think
they're sending anybody to save us?
I mean...
In case you haven't noticed,
we're doomed to spend the rest
of our miserable lives on this ship.
Maybe we should do it.
Do what?
It.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
We're not attracted now but,
we would emotionally attach.
You mean fall in love.
What if this awesome
thing we have going on
gets ruined?
People are meant to be together.
Oh, sorry, is this...
is this on?
Okay, ehm... lame.
We're both married.
I'm sure being adrift in space
gives you a hall pass.
You know what you
want to watch tonight?
Alien?
Never seen it.
Why the hell did we
watch that movie?